happy spooky season let's talk about
some celebrities that dressed up as
other celebs for Halloween here's
actress Megan Fox and musician Machine
Gun Kelly Justice Pamela Anderson and
Tommy Lee for Halloween in 2022 and
here's the real Pamela Anderson and
Tommy Lee next here's Jenna Ortega and
her then rumored boyfriend Asher Angel
perfectly dressed as Ariana Grande and
Pete Davidson back in 2018 and here's
the real iconic picture of Ariana and P
here's Courtney Kardashian and Travis
Barker dressed as punken icon Nancy
spongin and Sex Pistols member Sid
Vicious back in 2021 and here's the real
Nancy and Sid and finally here's music
legends Beyonce and Jay-Z just as low
Kim and Biggie Smalls for Halloween in
2017 and here's a real picture of music
legends Biggie Smalls and low Kim